help us understand like how exactly does
inflation work and then what is the
reasoning behind why we have the
inflationary model we have what's the
kind of defense of inflation well no
more on and I just it's provided the
world a lot of wealth right it's a the
is with him in an inflationary
environment for a long time our parents
grew up in it their parents grew up in
it and and so on and it's provided the
world a lot of wealth but in that the
assets go up in price so if you borrow
today with money you borrow from the
bank today
then with inflation your incomes will
rise over time
and the money will be worthless right
and so you pay that that money back
later on with inflation with dollars
that are worth less and and the asset
prices rise a good example as a house my
parents bought their first house for I
think it was 69 thousand dollars and in
the 70s that house is worth 1.5 million
today I'm the death it was paid back I
think they took a $59,000 my dad which
was a lot to that time and and they paid
it back over time as their incomes rose
so that's that's the world we live in
and it's not bad
some people win more right the debt
holders win more and everything else and
it's not a and it's not bad but without
a structural break and it's not coded
the structural breakers technology that
has changed the rules yeah
and so the current economic system we
have was really built for the old world
right and so if it was built for the old
world maybe describe a little bit about
your thought process of life that
Industrial Revolution type world is
dying and what I think you're arguing
here is the fact that we need a new
economic model for the world were going
into right it's kind of like we had an
old world with an old economic system
that old economic system matched the
world we're in now if the world changes
to this technology-enabled world now all
of a sudden you're arguing that we
she need a new economic model for the
future correct correct and and if you if
you look at this you can see it
everywhere by the way it's all of the
evidence points to it but people are
ignoring it because they don't want to
believe it and and so so so I'll give
some proof points you know it's probably
the best example that everybody has in
their hand is their iPhone or smartphone
that phone 20 was only invented there -
not quite 13 years ago right and and
look at the phone what's on it today
just about all your apps free you use
Google for free ways for free it's all
free so you have the power power more
than presidents had 20 years ago 30
years ago sitting in the palm of your
hands and it's all free it's a you can
buy and by the way it's not deflation
bad free we don't wait for when when the
new iPhone comes up there's a Lionel
around the block to buy it even though
you can get last year's for next to
nothing
on a plan of $20 a month and have
everything for free so that technology
deflation is a good thing okay
our Google searches or in fact that all
of the platform companies from music to
Google to Amazon it's all they're all
created actually using that same same
example you know technology or you're an
investor in technology I'm very much an
investor in technology and and it's a
good thing every technology executive I
work with is trying to do good in the
world and provide more efficiency and
better more abundance using technology
and that comes with the cost of jobs so
that's what's that that's what's
happening overall and it's accelerating
in the world
the only thing masking went is a massive
increase in debt and leverage where
you're pulling demand forward from the
future with debt that you can never pay
back in the future and so that massive
amount of debt and money and monetary
easing in the last 20 years to get
negligible inflation rights
is a hundred and eighty five trillion
dollars to produce 46 trillion dollars
of economic return in GDP
so when debt is growing way faster than
GDP you know something's wrong right and
and here's the thing this is before
covet this is before everything I
predicted all of these these events
before that before they were happening :
accelerates the trend to technology
right and it takes out or it's the zoom
went from 10 million users to 200
million users in a month how many of
those users don't need the same
commercial real estate when they come
back out of : and and so how much
changes how fast this changes how fast
robotics is changing how fast AI is is
moving people that aren't in close to
technology don't realize how fast this
is moving and and our old systems
weren't built for that technology
deflection because when if you have
deflation debt explodes in real terms
you can never pay it back so that if you
have if you have effectively economy
that's built on massive debt creation
and you allow deflation you have to
reset the debt and that's the problem
with the central bankers all over the
world are facing they don't know what to
do right and because this system and so
instead of doing what you instead of
facing the facts
you keep papering over the facts and
every time you paper over the facts if
you look at the stock market rising
because because of your juicing feds the
feds taking anything off the balance
sheets it's not capitalism you're
picking the pocket of this of the poor
and paying the rich because asset prices
go up and and that leads to division of
society revolutions and Wars and there's
a reset in that event and know no matter
what